Đây phương phát và đạo dạy nghen bài gọi không đừng giáo động trị trang huy rời
dùng công tương này mà để lấy lấy tìm xin nhẹ cái tác của liệu hợp như này
Sử dân các bạn một cách, chế lợp cho khẳng các thịt của gà hoạc không dẫn
Đó là cách, bà đạo
Để cho hai thứ hai người không cách nhớ chuyển mài hơn rồi
dùng công tương giả nghen quán lòng, để cho đây là một thức dụng tháng thịt giả nghen và tính nghen quán lòng
và một thời điểm bất kỳ như tuy tế một đế tế hai
dụng bà chỉ cần có phương trình rất nhiều qua thôi
là cho các bạn hãy tính ngược cái quá nơi này rồi
nhá, cho đi là các bạn cùng nghiêm qua
miêu qua cái thức dụng này mà chút
dây giờ, xe mà cái đâu, nhiều qua, các bạn có một phương trình là
ý bằng ăn thức của mình a là tế cục phía
và để quá nơi mình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình
tài thơ điểm, tài một đếm thơ điểm, tài hai
các bạn hãy sử dụng bối tình tư như sau
nhá, các bạn có tương này thì chưa bao nhiêu bất bình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình
thì các bạn nếu như bạn không biết thì bạn này bạn ở sử dụng
cho thấy trong ai ở này
dưới chào, cống tương này có thể nghe, tróng đường, xe màng
màu, in của nè, dây chào
ở, màu trên màu đàn, mấy màu đàn gì
màu đàn, một cái lấy phần müin, dây chào đàn, lấy phần müin
dột đàn, chí, tây hai, chú tây một chế chục bi
rất là các bạn, tính hình hình hình hình hình hình là đi a tế
bật chế chục bi
nó mặng bạn như thì mình là thần müin
bây giờ nó mặng mặng mặng mặng mặng mặng mặng mặng mặng mặng trường
thì chúng ta sẽ lấy màu đúng mạy
em nhau nhau
nhau, nhau, dạy, dạy màu đàn, màu đàn một thằng số
chúng ta có thể tính bóng, xác là để bà, màu đàn sẽ lấy màu, cái nhanh là đây
chúng ta sẽ lấy màu đồng, á đồng, trên để mình mặng, thân gàn
chí là trúc y, thế xa, lấy phần müin, nhau
nhau, thế thì thì cũng đau tìm màu đồng của nè
cũng đau thằng, nhưng màu đàn, hôm nay, thật sẽ nó đoán gọi em bằng
nhau, cũng số 2 là cũng thích phần, thế già, cũng thích phần
thế già, thích phần này thì có thông này tìm mình thì nó mấy tình bấm
thế già, thích phần mình được nó thích phần này
nhau, tất cả trên một thằng giới, và biểu trúc y trào
nhau, một thằng, một thích phần này nhau
thì cái cạnh nó giới nó sẽ là
tế mụt, quá, rất là cái tình đã xí tế mụt
cậm, quý màu, đình tầy, màu, đình trúc y
thế già, thằng số 2, trên nó sẽ là tế 2
nhau, và trong thích phần trường như giới, nó sẽ là phần trường quý
thế già, khoảng 2 nhau, đây là phần trường quý
thì, ở đây là xin, ở đây là có phía nhau
đây là phần trường quý nhau, đây là phần trường quý
chóa nhau, thế già, tính nhau, rận mà đây, cho 2 thì rục thành là trường quý rục
theo cái này, trong lệ bị rục mà 2 nhau
thế già, nhau có lòng, hồi phần trường quý bằng người cưỡ
bây giờ, tìm thì, thằng gọi màu, đình tầy, đình tầy, bằng không
thằng màu, đình thằng màu, đình thằng màu
nên là tầy, tầy là thằng lệ 2, thằng mất hợp là đình trường quý nhau
chí trúc kì
thế già, bác rất là lệ phần quý rục thành này
thế già, là dừng rất là nghe nhau, 2 phần bệ 5, 2, 2
thì nó chỉ hơn hơn được tý, đúng không?
đúng không?
phần quý rục thành này trong 1,5, đúng không?
dởi vì, màu, đây, em bởi phần quý rục thành này
đây là gây dưới nhất, các bạn tính trọng
cái câu dởi nghe này
và sau đó, các bạn sẽ ngon 1 phát cũng có gây gây gây bà là 3
ok, chạp
thế giới nước mất mất hình hoặc gà của gà của gà
cái thế giới lại các bạn nhé
màu, nhưng bụn này
gặp, tích phần này
tây 1 gặp màu, nhìn tầy
chia tầy 2, người đề tầy
chia mất tích phần là tầy, thầy cũng không phần xong
các bạn chỉ có bị bất máy là được
ok, chạp, anh yên chỉ có bị bất máy là được
không có bị tích phần là cái gì gà
ok, là, thế giới lại quá thay, các bạn có thể nghĩ việc hiểu rất này vào trong này
thế giới lại để phải là xin mong máy nhà
nào màu, thông muu cái góa nhé
màu, bụn này
a thì bạn bởi nó phương trình này
a, bụn nhìn bởi
thế giới lại
cậu, tích phần
quá
cậu, tích phần, tây 1 gặp màu, thân
cậu màu, tân tây, quá, màu, bụn, bụn, trúc hiểu
nó sẽ là 1 kiến 2
thế giới lại là hạt tự bấy đám đầy
bên trong này mình sẽ viết một cái phương trình của bây bất đầy
chóo, đi, đây có hả có phương trình của hả?
của hả?
có phương trình của bây bất đầy
nó sẽ là phương trình của bây bất đầy
là 2 mời bây bất đầy
hả?
xin, bây bây, 2
chói, bây bất đầy, có thương trình này thôi
chói nó thì hướng rất ngói em bảo này
cái này thì có thương đầy không có lần thảy hả?
thế giới lại hợp với thầy
hợp có thương đầy thôi
bởi nhá, bởi nhá, bởi nhá
nào, môn, nhìn bổn nơi này
à quên, chúc hiểu ở bên thế giải các bạn
mình sẽ là mại tình nát
cho mời tình rất là 2 chế độ
bấm mại, bấm góc, trả tình góc
Liên gree rất là chế độ đổn
ra rà diàn, ra chế độ dây
ra diàn rất là chế độ đổn
ra diàn, hả?
thì chí ho sình vào bây ra diàn, hả?
xíc này, nè như thế
nó vẫn đưa bí có bỏ xúc 2 này
chuyển vào bây ra diàn
thì ra, dưới bà chế truyền vào bây ra diàn
thì bấm nó sẽ dí sai
khi em chuy ở bây ra diàn, sau thì chó này là sẽ dư sau lấy
đúng không?
chuyền mời bí này
không tất ngay, nó không muốn nhận chết
cho ra là trong tất cả các mọi tình của quân
dư hỏi, gư có phân trên rất là nhiều hài
cho ra, có phân trên nhiều hài là ál đủ của các bạn
hả? cho ra phó bấm nhớ cho bạn nhá, thì ra sẽ quả đủ
ok, đây thì bấm cho bạn nhá, bấm bấm bằng này, ra sẽ quả đôi
đứt
lâm mê hai bỉ chỉ thái, thì ra đây chỉ là khoang rừng hả?
lâm mê hai bỉ chỉ thái, thì ra, đây chỉ là khoang rừng hả?